ninguém tá bom que bem mais apaixonado
assim tecnologia computadores jogo dela
com o atual esposa kay é o mesmo
o apelido dele e eles acabam se casando
alguma coisa boa eu fiz une esse
casamento a 2 subindo maravilhoso 2 a 1
em casa
então a essa esse movimento com
tecnologia veio desde sempre
em 2002 o blog blog anomia no twitter
emerson anomia em função do dólar e há
um ano morando hoje cinco semanas
sobriedade bebê é eu e minha vida estava
num momento muito ruim então eu resolvi
parar de beber
foi quando o projeto de três meses
quando aconteceu o acidente o capacete
em salvador
e eu me lembro bem na serra do dono
mas eu falei pô lo com os gastos
então é toda torcida que eu tinha lá e
todo aquele pessoal que incentivava
acompanhando projetar o fortaleza
eles embarcaram no projeto força é tal e
isso foi ao encontro de um ano
eu acho e é fascinante é o tema
principal da palestra motivação mas a
realidade do bem dizer que o bem é mais
viral que o mal
hoje em dia o contrário mas eu acho que
não vamos chegar lá eu enfim as pessoas
de um lado e eu acabava consolando do
super feliz estou bem mas depois eu o
meu título
nunca teve nenhuma sequela ele disse que
isso é uma questão de superação mesmo
resiliência
mas eu nunca me arrependi de ter ficado
paraplégica
se tiver sido o escolhido mas nunca
acontece por um motivo só hoje hoje para
dizer que hoje quando eu cheguei um
pouco atrasado e tinha acabado de falar
de manhã fala mais cedo
atrasei tinha acabado de instalar o
admilson apresentação de segurança de
água da casa em falar e falar em
arrependimento pelo fluminense por 1 a 1
isso pegou muito no ambiente online
as pessoas começaram continuar seguindo
outras novas chances de continuar muito
positiva
é uma coisa natural algumas pessoas não
pensam que é um burro negro a barra está
pesada é porque eu eu eu ressalto
escrevo isso no terra
eu ressalto que o bem geral de análise
muito mais do que um mais do que o
normal porque acaba bem
é então é você viu agora um justamente
no dia que recebi o convite e um desafio
do balde de gelo baixado até pensei cara
é nada
e repetindo que vai pegando nada bag
derrame de óleo e vamos lá mas só com os
mesmos são crianças passam muito rápido
descartei a viralização bem e que eu
gosto muito de atacar e eu coloco isso
diariamente toda vida que a gente acorda
de manhã você pode estar com raiva de
alguém
ontem falando isso pra mim no meu caso a
minha esposa fala muito sobre mim mas eu
gosto de deixar a mensagem como essa só
como o exponencial do mal que eu gosto
de bater na tecla e na verdade é um
universo novo bem é bem menor mais
conectado mas ao mesmo tempo a gente não
sabe direito onde eu acho eu vejo eu
vejo que a gente caminha pra um mundo
onde aquela criança que está sendo
bombardeada em gaza
ela passa a ser bombardeado em tempo
real e tuitando
ela estava cuidando então você tá você
acaba sendo mais humana
então essa questão de que a aaa
negativismo com muitas pessoas já não
acabou nada mais perto da uma e sete
tudo bem eu não só vejo o contrato eu
sei que realmente é o povo
davi falou que essa em site do
fantástico e as mídias online são
ferramentas é incrível espero que a
gente possa é é utilizá-los superação e
persistência e força de vontade
gabrielli em ter 100 blogs 11 em uma
violenta seu ganha-pão 4 na maratona
feminina de los angeles
a suíça gabrielli andersen marca a
história da sony um dia né cambaleou até
a linha de chegada observadas de perto
por um pouquinho de médicos em cujos
traços ela desabou após concluir os 42
quilômetros da prova
tá
ao chegar aqui mas a imagem que foi
realizado nessa questão de superação
acho que ela está no dna de cada um de
nove delas é a mulher também aumenta a
lei que houve mas ela não disse isso é
muito a filosofia do criador
acho que todo mundo já deve ter visto
várias vezes eu só lembro dela ganhou da
rosa moto por mesa
o que mais me ajudou nessa minha
recuperação foi o uso de um esporte
mapeavam voltar a fazer o mesmo porque
você não existe há sete anos atrás
acidente antes de morar no são paulo na
noite do dia 1º
o que não me sai da cabeça foi não
desistir a redes sociais e parentes de
pessoas apenas de apenas para passeio de
infância
o médico que tinha um protocolo indicado
para o tratamento de câncer é eu
encontrei via blog pesquisa e de dez
minutos e meio então acompanhando
mergulhei nessa mas ainda não as mídias
sociais é aaa a essa imagem e vídeo
mostra muito isso e não existir
realmente acaba ganhando por isso que
que eu ressalto tanto não só no facebook
na com naná
nas demais redes essa questão é a
questão do bem viral é geral porque
porque acabam fazendo muito mais
eu desafio qualquer pessoa a mostrar a
campanha na nba a agredir tudo você
pergunta campanha legal lançando para
ajudar uma criança tipo ou outro de
banco que foi a lista de desejos
ela queria arrecadar doações para fazer
os últimos exames dela vir avisou que é
uma beleza
essas campanhas acabam ganhando porque a
gente hoje vive em um universo
completamente diferente de uma década
atrás
a gente hoje basicamente pode estar só
geograficamente no quarto do hospital
pede o o doença
o mundo hoje é um único coração da gente
nós puls a ele bate sozinho e é
basicamente esse gráfico
eu vou falar dos mesmos já gráfico vou
mostrar pra mostrar o mundo pulsa e é o
ar sensação nal
esse batimento cardíaco ao mundo aqui
perfeita
ah
bem pra finalizar é é esse mundo hoje
batido mesmo pulsar no mito batida eu
solto minuto deixei o final
antes de ir pra casa tava vendo assim ao
ouvir que é um cara que vai apresentar o
programa ao vivo na tv local e o cara
simplesmente trava começa a gravar em 1
hora que ele ligasse e isso mesmo a musa
de deus
com isso me tira do a acontece no começo
eu fiquei com medo de ter travado então
eu travei
eu queria agradecer muito o convite foi
botar com você desenvolve um grande